we've documented his greatest moments to
some of his worst from the highest of
the lows Golan has never failed to be an
exceedingly interesting character for us
to discuss and while he hasn't
participated as much as we would have
liked during supers run recently a fire
has returned to Gohan's eyes which has
led many fans to claim that he is
stronger now than he ever has been with
this series I want to bring you the most
detailed fact bearing analysis I can and
while I am pleased with my previous
power level series entry was gone there
were one or two fatal errors that may be
End figure completely inaccurate we were
here to rectify that today and show you
why go on is in fact much much stronger
than I previously stated I'm totally not
Marc and this is a power level series
episode 5.5 Son Gohan
today we will focus on Dragon Ball super
primarily but before that I want to
rectify something that has bothered me
hugely since I uploaded the Gohan power
level series episode so let's venture
back to the cell saga the moment Cell
touches down the battlefield to absorb
the androids at this point in my last
video I became more anecdotal than facts
bearing and I apologize for this while
there was evidence to support the theory
that cells absorption ability worked on
an addition scale there were clear
indicators that cell was designed with
absorbing the androids in mind meaning
the androids would yield much more than
a simple addition based increase but I
am getting way ahead of myself here
let's set scene and take it from there
currently imperfect cell is clocking in
around 400 million piccolo at Android 17
are standing at around 360 million and
finally Android 18 at roughly 330
million so taking into account that the
androids are more valuable to sell than
Vegeta
Goku or any of the other stronger
fighters it's fair to say that they
yield a more satisfying result my use of
the word satisfying here is intentional
there are many out there that believe
perfect cell has a pre-designed max
power once he absorbs both androids
I however disagree with that and I'll
tell you why I'm sure many of you out
there are familiar with team 4 stars
work on the hit parody Dragon Ball Z
abridged in which cell is portrayed as a
nefarious sexual innuendo spewing
deviant
however while hilarious it is actually
much closer to cells character than you
might think
self continuously refers to his complete
self throughout the series as
quote-unquote perfect which by
definition means cannot be improved upon
and that simply in cells case at least
is not true so why this logical fallacy
would sell well it simply boils down to
nature cell is a completely biological
being albeit artificial and like any
biological creature he has needs or
instincts he must either follow or
suppress in sales case he follows them
in the real world humans don't simply
want sex it's much more than that
our instincts our bodies push us in that
direction this is an evolutionary trait
to preserve our species it's not a
choice it's in our genetic makeup to
pursue this in sales case he was
designed by dr. gyro on a cellular level
he needs to absorb his Android nothing
consumes and more so his goal is now
clear become strong enough to defeat and
then absorbed the androids
the point
I'm trying to make here is that while
the androids yield a more powerful
result he is not necessarily doing it
for that reason he wants needs desires
to simply be complete with that clear
once Android 17 is absorbed cell attains
his second form semi-perfect cell in
this form he is clearly stronger than
Android 16 who serves to juxtapose how
strong cell used to be with this cell is
at least over twice as strong as Android
16 who we now know has a power level in
the region of 400 million which is known
to us l must be in the region of 1
billion meaning absorbing an Android
leads to a 2.5 times increase if we
multiply it by a further 2 point 5 we
get 2.5 billion in his perfect cell form
capable of pushing it to 3 billion when
going all out and why is this figure
significant well this means that Super
Saiyan grade 2 Vegeta's power level must
fall somewhere in the region of 1
billion and 2.5 billion around this time
very much much closer to the 1 billion
mark when he faced semi-perfect cell so
I would estimate him to be in the region
of 1.25 billion significantly stronger
than semi-perfect so at this time but
not anywhere close to perfect cell at
this time it's worth knowing that
Vegeta's final flash to perfect cell is
not indicative of its power level at all
in previous episodes I have cited this
quote which states that the Z fighters
or people who can control their ki are
capable of amplifying their strength in
huge bursts this is exactly what the
Kamehameha final flash and makankosappo
are designed for to amplify the user's
existing power to a heightened state now
what does all this have to do with
anything I hear you question well it's
all set for this moment when Gohan and
Goku exit the hyperbolic time chamber go
on and Goku at this stage in this series
have attained full mastery of the Super
Saiyan form or as I explained in my
previous video Super Saiyan grade for
this next part is important and I missed
it in my last video Goku and Gohan
stopped off a Correns place while there
Goku requests Korra to compare his power
to cell Goku in that moment powers up to
half strength that instance is hugely
important when it comes to scaling this
portion of the series with half of this
full power
Goku amazes piccolo trunks and Vegeta
thus meaning that Goku 1/2 power is
stronger than Vegeta who we have
currently sitting at around 1.25 billion
this means that go on is around 2.5
billion or more before transforming into
the Super Saiyan 2 form as stated in my
previous video the Super Saiyan 2
multiplier is times 2 which means that
if we take Cohen's existing power level
that we have estimated as being in the
region of 2.5 billion in a Super Saiyan
2 state go on emits a power level
greater than 5 billion right so now that
we have this more accurate figure to
bounce off of let's take a look at the
rest of the series and I'll try to keep
it brief where I can following the
collapse of the Cell Games the earth
returns to an era of peace for seven
years during which go on trains either
seldomly or not at all in my previous
video I reduced his power by 25% I based
this off of a quote from Vegeta
referring to go on strength at this
given time bringing his power during the
early Buu saga to that of 3.75 billion
when channeling Super Saiyan 2 at this
level Gohan is floored by majin buu and
remains lifeless until he is transported
to the world of the Kai's where his
power is unlocked by the elder Kai with
his power haven't been unlocked Goku is
simply blown away by how powerful Gohan
has become this should be indicative
that go on at this time is now stronger
than Goku Super Buu at this moment in
time has a power level of around 24
billion I know it sounds insane but
trust me this will make sense once I
explained my process during Goku's power
level series if I ever get around to it
once everything is scaled and taken into
account go on in his ultimate form is
fully capable of taking out Super Buu
with relative ease putting them in the
region of 30 billion or more at the end
of the Buu saga which finally brings us
to Dragon Ball super and this if you
believe it is where things start to get
complicated
before I begin I wanted to be known that
I won't be using any information
provided by the movie battle of gods
this movie was created without the
future of the series in mind and as a
result won't be taken into account when
talking about Dragon Ball super however
as it pertains to resurrection F which
was released in 2015
mere month before Dragon Ball super was
released it seems fair to state that
this movie is more representative of
torreón his frame of mind when preparing
his notes for the first two acts of the
show so what nowadays counts as canon to
the series Dragon Ball super well Akira
Toriyama is involved in the production
of both the movie resurrection F the
anime Dragon Ball super and
the Dragon Ball super manga adaptation
it's been stated in past interviews by
Toyota row the main illustrator behind
the Dragon Ball super manga the Toriyama
hands him words on paper as the outline
for the plot sort of like signposts to
hit as the story progresses it's fair to
assume given that Dragon Ball super has
a team of writers that if Toriyama was
to be involved he would give them the
same bullet points as he gave Toyo taro
to create the manga but why is this
significant well it means that if we
look at the commonalities between
resurrection F and the series adaptation
of Dragon Ball super we should be able
to find what is the material written by
Akira Toriyama
and what is formulated by the Toei
writing staff that said once we pass the
resurrection F section of the story I
will only use the Dragon Ball super
anime is telling on the event seeing as
those are the events we are concerned
with at the end of the day
alrighty so let's begin the events of
Dragon Ball super take place roughly
four years after the majin buu arc of
Dragon Ball Z during this time go on has
neglected to Train favoring his life as
a scholar and family man during the beer
Suisse introduction unearthed after the
brief altercation that go on has with
beerus piccolo remarks at how quote even
Gohan was beaten as easily this could be
indicative of Golin at this time being
the strongest warrior on the ship far
surpassing piccolo however it should
also be noted that we as the viewers
have been given no indication that
piccolo knows how strong Vegeta
currently is either the ultimate form
unlock provided by the elder Kai is a
topic of fierce debate in the fandom
hopefully I can clear up a few
misconceptions from this section of the
story from this quote the elder Kai
describes his ability he states with my
psychic powers I can take the hidden
power which anyone has no matter how
amazing a master they may be and draw it
way way out above their limit this is a
hugely important quote and I think harms
and the team over arc I sent you for
providing these accurate translations
from the original manga this quote tells
us that no matter the recipient of the
power of they will be able to exceed
their limits this is important as it
means regardless of how little training
Gohan does as long as he is able to tap
into this form he has his ultimate power
this quote is equally as important and
telling while it shows Goku fangirling
over Gohan's newly acquired power it
also contains a small crucial piece of
information from the elder Kai
pertaining to the Super Saiyan
transformation ad the ultimate form
Goku comments on Gohan's appearance
having not changed hardly at all and not
even having done Super Saiyan the elder
Chi chimes in by stating transforming
isn't good
that's Super Saiyan whatever it's called
is the wrong way of doing things
meaning Gohan's ultimate form is the max
and therefore he does not require the
Super Saiyan form at all and I hope
that's cleared up a few misconceptions
amongst the fanbase well I hope for
people to understand from this is that
there is no evidence to support the
theory that Gohan can stack Super Saiyan
on to his ultimate form in fact there is
evidence to dispute this theory from the
original writings just so we have this
straight according to the manga Gohan's
ultimate form is his full potential push
past its limits specifically without the
Super Saiyan transformation if Gohan was
capable of utilizing his ultimate form
in tandem with his Super Saiyan form why
would he not have used it to defeat
majin buu when they fought put quite
simply that theory just doesn't make
sense and I hope everyone is now on the
same page moving forward to the
resurrection a spark another topic of
contention in the fanbase is the
statement Gohan makes referring to
Takuma go on States and I quote
he's hiding his power and might be as
strong as me at my best
referring to Tajima after he has powered
up many people believe that statement is
indicative of Takuma being as strong as
ultimate Gohan from the Buu saga and my
response to this might prove to be
unsatisfactory for some of you but in
truth I do not believe that to be the
case
not for one solitary second in fact I
don't believe tagamet exists this lon
into the resurrection of that story
written by Akira Toriyama and I have
some evidence to support my theory the
Dragon Ball super manga and the
resurrection F movie both have talked
about killed by Frieza once he was
resurrected on board his own ship if we
compare the commonalities between all of
these tellings of the story one glaring
difference is the included autonomous
portrayal on the battlefield of Earth
and there are so many things wrong with
that scene in particular it's actually
frightening it completely disregards the
stories established logic for the sake
of a nostalgic callback allow me to
break this down looking at this quote
from episode 21 we see survey referring
to talk about as being stronger than the
ginyu force and I assume he means the
strongest of them captain ginyu this
statement serves to only prepare the
audience for captain ginyu arrival which
again did not feature any other telling
except the anime
inu is confirmed to have a para level of
120,000 in volume 24 on the manga and
that is the power level that sorbet is
referring to at the beginning of episode
22 tagamet takes an unguided blow from
piccolo to the face while smiling in
episode 22 at 12:21 tagamet punches out
tension on Curlin piccolo Gohan and
Master Roshi now we know that ginyu
cannot read power levels and so would
have dealt the same force blow to all
the fighters which begs the question why
Master Roshi wasn't killed
so when you say tagamet is as strong as
Gohan's best as strong as captain ginyu
and Master Roshi is able to take an
unguided punch the same way piccolo and
Gohan er I don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about and so I hope you
can see my problem including this
section for consideration the Ptolemaic
character was created by Akira Toriyama
and he was used in taureanas story
however Toriyama wanted to use this
character to display Frieza sadistic
side in both the manga and the movie
when he kills tagamet for speaking out
of turn with that information it is my
belief that this scene was not included
by Akira Toriyama and should be
considered as filler in the series the
writing staff at OE simply took
liberties with Akira Toriyama's
bullet-points expanding upon them and as
a result we saw many many
inconsistencies if you look at these
episodes a large portion of them are
flashbacks from Dragon Ball Z and really
that's the main reason I believe they
went this route it's well documented
that Dragon Ball super animation
suffered hugely during this time which
was 100% down to bad scheduling
decisions on toys part this was a way
for them to buy time for other episodes
to be made using as little new animation
as they could when I take everything I
just stated into account I cannot take
this scene into consideration when
calculating Gohan's power level either
all of its good to use or none of it is
good to use at all there isn't much more
to talk about when it pertains to go on
as I've already stated Gohan's ultimate
4 most likely is a solid unwavering
power that is indifferent to the users
current level we are currently on
episode 84 of Dragon Ball super go on
and still not being seen to reacts as
his ultimate form yet however as stated
in my previous video in the new opening
of the show we can clearly see Gohan
gaining access to his ultimate form once
again I'm sorry that this wasn't the
conventional power level series episode
but I felt things needed to be corrected
and made clear for my
last video plus the next episode is
going to be huge so I need time to iron
out the kinks on that one that said I
really hope you enjoyed this video don't
forget to leave a like and if you did
enjoy this episode feel free to
subscribe for more Dragon Ball analysis
and content this has been the power
level series kind of I'm totally not
mark thank you so much for watching